[Musique]
c'est à s'y méprendre on croirait un
grand rassemblement politique de wakfu
de l'ancien maire de toronto
son grand frère dog le même style
combatif il se présente lui aussi en
défenseur du simple contribuable c'est
pas des gens qui ont été fabriquées par
une machine politique
ils sont très direct ils sont très
populiste ils ont une vision peut-être
ancestral de la vie politique des
presque des individus politique de la
vieille garde
si on remettait le politicien
d'expérience d'oxford l entrepreneur du
clan selon le globe and mail il était
vendeur de drogue dans les années 80 il
réfute ces allégations et aucune
accusation n'a été portée
dr le président de l'entreprise
familiale décoller brenntag depuis 2002
il est donc moins engagé socialement que
l'été son jeune frère dogg avait aussi
beaucoup de responsabilités en termes de
business familial et c'était lui qui
avait ramené la belle-famille d'une
business qui avait beaucoup beaucoup de
succès mais quelque chose qui est devenu
vraiment internationale c'est d'ailleurs
sous la gouverne de dog folk décoller
brenntag d'ajouter des usines à chicago
et au new jersey
tout comme sur 37 millionnaire qui se
hisse en tribunes du parc
et c'est là un aspect un peu bizarre qui
réussit enfin la politique c'est
vraiment une affaire de famille pour les
ford de père était député provincial
dans le gouvernement de mike harris
pendant les années 90 watts pour lui a
été conseiller municipal pendant dix ans
avant de devenir maire de toronto puis
dog a été conseiller municipal dans la
ville reine lorsque son frère était
maire et leur 9e michael est conseillé à
son tour depuis deux ans dans le secteur
est au big o et tobiko encore et
toujours le château fort des fraudes
il reflète vraiment leur quartier
aussitôt mikko est vraiment est vraiment
quartier fascinant parce que je pense
qu'il représente vraiment le vrai le
vrai toronto le vrai est la vraie
province de l'ontario bariolés
multiethnique très migrants des gens qui
ont fait fortune au 6 mai qui m'aimait
des gens ce qu'ils étaient deux classes
moyennes c'est pour cette raison que doc
fraude rêve plus que jamais de diriger
la plus grande province du pays dès juin
prochain
il siffle épreuve la radio canada
toronto